[Music]
it's a new month which means six more
video games to add to your collection
are you PlayStation Plus subscribers
will be getting to PlayStation 4 games
to PlayStation 3 and 2 for the Vita as
well
we have spot puzzle aura exploration and
action games for you this month let's
start with the big guns on ps4 NBA 2k16
tops the list and if you're from the US
you are probably much happier than the
rest of the world with this one but I
wanted to tell everyone to play this
game don't worry if basketball isn't the
sport for you the career mode in this
game is fantastic and worth your time
and the face Canon has been improved
which really helps to immerse you in the
game the career mode itself is directed
by Spike Lee the same Spike Lee who
directed Malcolm X and Inside Man if
that doesn't float your ball then look
at the ratings instead the current
Metacritic score is 87 out of 100 IGN
and GameSpot gave it 9 and 8
respectively the second offering for ps4
users is gone home a first-person
exploration game let's get one thing
straight about this game it is slow it
is really methodical they'll be
breathing an awful lot to get the full
perspective on the narrative you don't
actually meet any other players in the
game you just look around so keep that
in mind so if you look for something
with more action probably steer clear
from this one but if you like games like
fire watch your everyone's gone to the
rapture you'll love this Metacritic
currently has this game at 85 out of 100
IGN gave it a huge 9.5 over to the ps3
now and we are given quirky eco chrome
this game is based around perspective
and rotating the camera to give your
character the ability to maneuver around
in possible situations if you haven't
guessed already this is your puzzle game
for the month and currently holds a
Metacritic score of 81
siren blood curse is your other option
on ps3 the game is an adventure horror
outing that combines Silent Hill and The
Walking Dead it's been around almost 10
years so don't expect too much and you
won't be disappointed
Kirt metacritic scarf 78
the PlayStation Vita may no longer be
supported by major parties but there are
still great games to find and play this
month Vita users received yet another
God of War game this time is Chains of
Olympus it plays just as you remember in
2008 and is a respectable part from the
PSP version Metacritic has given this
game a whopping 91 out of 100 the
Flavians rounds out this month's games
and takes full advantage of the touchpad
your role is to navigate and protect the
little deviants in a range of gimmicky
minigames and levels you'll be singing
and maneuvering your Vita in ridiculous
ways so don't play this one on your
commute to work or school that's it
that's all six games for the month in
total you'll be receiving about 105
pounds worth of games if you're from the
UK and about 140 dollars if you're in
the US what do you think about this
month's games sound off below if you've
enjoyed this video if it's helped stop
please consider subscribing thanks for
your time and I'll see you soon
[Music]